we will incorporate this in our own
application so you can fully expect us
to obviously every product of Microsoft
will have some of the same AI
capabilities to completely transform the
product
to jump right into it uh let's talk
about uh artificial intelligence uh it's
a big topic already in everybody's mind
here
there's already been quite a bit of
speculation given to me that in seven or
eight years this interview will be
conducted by some kind of artificial
intelligence which might make it better
that there won't be journalists here
there'll be machines doing all of the
work which also could be an improvement
for all I know
um you guys obviously are an investor in
open AI
um you've invested more there are many
reports out there that you are looking
to invest more I think 10 billion has
been thrown around as the number out
there
um
you see that you have an inside view of
the technology can you just
put in some broad perspective
we saw the demo we've all experienced it
we see the sort of the dramatic impact
it has how do you assess
really holistically where the technology
is and isn't what it does what it
doesn't do and how big a breakthrough
moment we're at
yeah first of all
um
yeah I wish I put chat GPD through that
security line myself
um
there
let me just kind of give you two
anecdotes and then um try to generalize
it um on New Year's Day this year I just
looked in my news feed and I saw this
tweet
um that Andre karapati who is um you
know who was the the guy
um at Tesla who you know did the
autopilot uh tweeted saying uh 80 of the
code he writes today is being written by
uh GitHub co-pilot
think about this right this is one of
the most elite AI Developers
who is saying that they're being that
much more productive it's not that Andre
is not doing great AI work it's just
that a lot he's getting a ton of
Leverage
and that's perhaps been the Breakthrough
product of this generation of AI in the
last year uh and it's a real product
it's not some research project somewhere
what have you I mean this is some
literally changing uh the productivity
curve for some of the most uh for
software Engineers which was considered
the knowledge worker
um you know or rather the most sort of
difficult to automate knowledge work so
to speak and so that's one then the next
day I was I was in India and I saw this
demo which was just completely stunning
for me
um I saw
someone use one of the Indian vernacular
languages
um talking to a bot that Microsoft
research along with our partners uh from
the ministry of electronics and a
program called bashini which is about
trying to basically use uh AI to get
language translation to be democratized
in India but so here's essentially
someone who is in rural India using one
of their language you know of a local
language talking to a bot on WhatsApp
and uh this bot basically this person
wanted to have access to some government
program
um and so he asks about the program the
bot comes back and says you should go to
the portal and do X Y and Z and uh he
then goes on to say that look I don't
want to go to the portal just do this
for me
and so this is someone in rural India
um sort of expressing a pretty complex
thought uh even if uh they may not be
all literate about how to navigate some
complex set of instructions
and then on the back end of it what the
the team had done was used GPT
to essentially train over all of
government of India's documents and made
it accessible in every Indian language
and made it automatable
think about this I'd never seen in my
life at least in the 30 years I've been
in Tech ever a demo where an advance
that happened in say West Coast to the
United States
shows up in very real terms
for someone in rural India within months
I mean that is diffusion of technology
that I've never seen I don't think it
happened in the industrial revolution
but maybe this time around
in what is sort of the knowledge worker
equivalent of the Industrial Revolution
it's going to help everybody so these
two things so the most elite AI
developer on one end and on the other
end there is a rural farmer in India
being able to access uh government
programs through AI
so that's
Sonic don't
what the power of this thing is and
from what you see and where we're at are
we
are we at the early stage of a curve
that's rapidly going to change in the
next few years and we're going to see
this this kind of exponential
development I think that's that's the
key so what you just said was what is
why is there so much more excitement
this year than last year
is because of that exponential uh growth
of the power of these models I'm not
claiming by the way that this is the
last innovation in AI or this is the
last Model architecture uh there's going
to be lots more to come but if you look
at what has happened between GPT 3 to 3
5 to what comes next these are not
linear areas this is not linear progress
uh okay but the past the slightly
pessimist case you're an optimist on
this would be
it's exciting it's it's rapidly moving
it's a bit terrifying the knowledge
workers I heard it already here at Davos
this week already anxious in some ways
about their future jobs and what it
means when you see technology spread on
that scale I have to ask one are we
societally ready for that and are you
really confident that there's The
Optimist case that it enhances all of
our productivity rather than replace as
many of us it's a it's a great it's the
right question to ask I mean look I mean
the first thing I step back and say
when I look at all productivity data I
look at all economic growth data
I sort of look at that and say God we
need something
to help us it's not like we're as a
world growing at inflation-adjusted
three four percent if you really have
the dream that the eight billion people
Plus in the world they're living
standards monotonically should keep
improving year over year what is that
input that's going to cause that cause
that like what you know we need and we
have some tough challenges right when
you think about energy transition let's
just take that for an example
essentially what we're saying at least
the way I as a Layman lay person
understand it is you got to take 250
years of chemistry and compress it into
some 25 years uh so that we can then
make it to the other side if that is the
case computational uh chemistry is going
to be super important and so
applications of AI to that is probably
the way we're going to make it so I look
at it and say we need something
that truly changes the productivity
curve so that we can have real economic
growth
and then if you have that there are all
kinds of things that we can like talk
about which is what does it mean to
displacement which will be real after
all there was displacement in the
industrial revolution we went through
some lot of hardship to come up with
even an understanding of how to deal
with it this time around we have that
understanding uh so therefore I would
say first let's not fall into what is
the lump of Labor fallacy if you don't
fault for that then what are all the new
jobs what is the training required and
here's one other thing I'd say Matt
which uh if you think about the
the wave Frontline workers today are
being enabled with technology
to be able to do what was previous ly
perhaps considered knowledge work it's
probably the biggest thing that is
underreported underwritten about then
you know we have at Microsoft a tool
called Power Platform right so think of
it as what is essentially it's Excel
level skills at best uh even lower where
you can take that tool and create
applications create workflows in fact
you can use GPT to essentially prompt a
workflow so that means somebody who's in
the retail Frontline Warehouse Frontline
Healthcare Frontline pick your favorite
uh Frontline job where they're not I.T
Specialists they're not skilled in
computer science they can in fact
participate in the digital
transformation of their org if they do
that what happens next is better wages
because they're now considered to be not
just doing Frontline work but are also
participating in what was previously
knowledge work so to me that that's an
example of in fact people participating
in the labor force with better support
I'm going to ask you though
what concerns you when you see you see
seeing things that we haven't seen yet
that aren't public yet you see what's
coming tell us a little bit about what
we haven't seen publicly and then what
you know
what's a little bit about where it's
going
I mean I
the thing that
all the concerns we have around safety
whether it's harmful content or
hallucination or any of these you just
need to buy design like I mean all
software engineering has to shift left
you have to sort of think about the
model itself being safe then you have to
on top of it have a safety system that
is built and so you have to really take
this as a first class engineering
concern uh and build and this is not new
to just AI it's true in any other
category of software today as well but
what do we what do we need to be doing
as a society and maybe even for the
folks in this room a lot of them are
knowledge workers as individuals
to be thinking about repairing ourselves
for what's coming because as you just
sort of even hinted we haven't wrapped
our heads around social media and what
hit us 20 years ago this is going to be
exponentially faster and probably have a
more dramatic impact in the short term
on our society how do we need what do we
need to be thinking about societally you
know the
Vicky's eye come at it is
I grew up with sort of the PC Revolution
starting in the late 80s
um and it was just an empowering moment
right I mean even if you think about my
own story I mean the way I I was able to
sort of have this technology reach me
where I was growing up and be able to
sort of get into it and then you know
and the rest is you know history so
therefore I look at it and say is it
doesn't matter if you are a knowledge
worker or a Frontline worker use these
tools to actually then get more leverage
in your job if if andrage as a software
developer in AI can do that uh why can't
all of us have access to it uh what if
that farmer in rural India can use this
technology to get their job done that's
the way I think the best way to prepare
for it is to sort of not bet against
this technology and this technology
helping you in your job in your business
process and especially at a time like
this Matt like here we are right we have
inflation we have all of this
macroeconomic headwinds doing more with
less is perhaps more of a premium and so
if I find any technology that allows us
to be more productive let's take that
and then let's create that economic
surplus and then talk about how to
distribute it in all the ways and there
are many many mechanisms one can talk
about well I mean when you talk about
productivity I'm going to talk ask you
about productivity in general a sense
but some people hear things like we have
to be more productive and they think
right with fewer human beings
so you're obviously very optimistic you
obviously see it what is
can you just talk a little bit about
what might be concerning or cautionary
about it as as it as it becomes more
widely adopted yeah I mean I think
Automation and the question I take even
what's happening with tech jobs today
um interestingly enough if you look at
it there was as Tech Supply in what is
considered the tech industry is now
sort of basically getting more
distributed because every Auto Company
every Pharma company every retail
company needs to hire tech people so to
some degree we should not think of
Automation in one company to mean that
that person uh is not required elsewhere
and so the question is what are all what
is the overall capacity for the economic
economy and Society to absorb and create
new jobs and that I think is going to be
the real and then the other thing that
we should also have is wage support for
different jobs I've always felt like why
is there such disparity today in the job
in the labor market between let's say
some care worker and let's call it sort
of a software developer
and it's because we think of that we as
a society have decided to give it
different
um I'd say premium those premiums will
adjust as some of these Technologies uh
really truly get diffused okay well the
diffusion seems key when I think about
the theme this year at Davos so
fractionalization and there's a lot of
talk in the hallways here about the new
globalization uh the the implication of
the technology obviously go beyond
National borders quite quickly and quite
dramatically when you talk about the
impact you see in in India uh it's not
just software jobs moving from Silicon
Valley to Boise Idaho but really
potentially everywhere around the world
very quickly here
yeah I mean look up the the idea that
every country has to have social
cohesion based on the jobs and The
Economic Opportunity I think is much
better understood today than let's call
it the first phase of globalization
whatever happens in the sort of this
this phase of globalization is not going
to repeat the mistakes of the previous
era where when there is displacement
happening in a society I think everybody
is going to focus on what do we do about
those people who are getting displaced
getting trained getting new jobs so I
think now we have to in some sense to
your point really account for both
forces a globalization force uh you know
David Ricardo was not wrong there is
going to be competitive advantage of
Nations and things will still exist
where there is a reason why people will
want to globalize but at the same time
all every politician gets elected
because of local politics and they want
to care a lot more about jobs locally
and so therefore in fact that's the
right balance to have last question on
this uh we want to talk about a few
other things but
it's a bit hypothetical of course
particularly given the scale of change
of the technology but have you wrapped
your head around it as you look at it if
you thought about a company like
Microsoft five years from now 10 years
from now
what this widespread adoption of the
technology of chat GPT means for how
you're organized how you're structured
how you do work
what the real actual implications are
going to be on the ground have you have
you been able to think that through very
much and when you look ahead what do you
see absolutely I mean this is the one of
the the hottest things that you learn
um in in a tech company
uh you know we're what 48 years old
today and
um it's hard because you have to adjust
the means of production essentially in
our Tech business changed dramatically
and that it requires us to unlearn and
learn uh which is always very
unforgiving quite frankly and um if you
look at what even these large models or
foundational models are it's very
different in fact I would say one of the
things that is perhaps the toughest
thing is the previous era AI expert
is the one that is going to have the
hardest time
shifting to this new paradigm because
everything all the assumptions oh my God
here is my data I'm going to train on
that data my data is the only thing that
matters all that's not a question you
now have a large model which can be used
as a retrieval engine on your data
that's going to perform better than sort
of something that you trained on for
your on your data I mean just the
intuition just so that people have what
this is suppose you train a model on
let's say all the math formulas yeah
it'll it'll get pretty efficient in math
but let's say you train a model on all
the math formulas and all the human text
there is on the web
it gets better at math
and you say wow how is that possible of
course it's possible because when we
went to school it's not like we just
learned math we learned math we learned
history we learned language and so yeah
so something so that emergent capability
is a pretty different thing than like
whatever we were even a couple of years
ago as state of our state of the art in
terms of AI so do we need to learn math
anymore why learn math well let me tell
you I'm an electrical engineer who never
understood the Maxwell's equations so
now I finally get thanks to chat GPT a
better understanding of it so I think
one of the things is we will all enjoy a
lot more math because we will have that
personalized tutor who will in fact be
able to intervene at The crucial time
when you're making a conceptual mistake
and help you learn so just imagine that
just what if there was a fantastic tutor
teacher for every student learning math
going forward that is now possible
okay well I I'm gonna break my word
because I want to ask you one more thing
which I uh on this then we'll move on
which is short term I think we have a
story that I think is coming today just
that in the short term you guys are
making more tools available through in
Microsoft with the AI how will we see it
affect Microsoft and our engagement with
Microsoft in the near term just talk a
little bit about what you're playing
yeah I mean look at Microsoft the
I think it's probably what stating is
this didn't just happen uh that is chat
GPT uh and GPT family of models this is
something that we've been partnered with
open AI deeply now for multiple years
and we built in Azure our public Cloud
infrastructure uh an AI supercomputer uh
which by the way as a systems
architecture has been a massive
breakthrough because the way these
workloads or the the way you train large
models is very different than anything
uh out there it's a much more
large-scale synchronous distributed job
so we have to build the system from
Storage to compute to network that
really allowed us to even build this
capability so I at this point the way
Microsoft's going to really
commercialize all of this is azure has
become the place for anybody and
everybody who thinks about Ai and
large-scale training and we're way ahead
on that and we continue to plan to sort
of really step it up there second is
we're going to make these foundational
models available as platforms so that
means anybody who wants to build on them
in any domain uh can build on top of
that soon in fact today we just made the
Azure open AI uh service available
generally and then even chat GPT will be
available as an API and so we're very
excited about that and then we will
incorporate this in our own application
so you can fully expect us to obviously
at every product of Microsoft will have
some of the same AI capabilities to
completely transform the product
okay so we'll be seeing it soon let me
hit on a couple other topics while I've
got you so you productivity you've
mentioned a couple of times in relation
to AI but more broadly you've been
talking a lot about productivity in this
uh workplace moment uh Microsoft which
we should say has certainly has a good
business of remote work and helping
facilitate it but you you you've sort of
suggested that uh from your research
work from home is not necessarily as
unproductive as many bosses are saying
that it is but at the same time you've
also wanted more some presence of people
in the office what's the balance in your
mind now for being in the office being
at home and maximizing productivity but
still having a healthy culture and and
connectivity what's right for you do you
think yeah I mean look there is
there are three things at least we
observe in the data that we are at in
aggregate that we use to even inform our
own set of policies
the first is what you reference which is
there is this what I would call a
paranoia around productivity right every
boss thinks that somehow they're not
being as productive every person working
thinks that they're burnt out so there
is uh this dichotomy
um of at least how people feel uh and I
think the only way out of that is to
have data right not Dogma uh which is
you know the ultimately we are all going
to be responsible for the outcomes and
if we're managing to the outcomes uh
then we'll be better off so that's sort
of one side of it the second thing I'd
say is we also all have to recognize
that people come for other people not
for policy just because I said that
everyone needs to be at work you know
it's just not going to matter but I
think we all have to learn some new soft
skills as leaders and managers where
convening people like if I say I'm I
have a meeting
or I have an event
and make that event exciting I think I
would say I say like the new management
technique is all of us are event
managers
um and I think that's so we'll have to
learn many new software you know soft
management techniques in order to get
people to connect with people because
it's important so go ahead and then the
last thing I'd say is even recruitment
right which is one of the things that
it's fascinating to see like people want
to feel connected to the company it's
culture and also feel that they're
making progress and so we have to go
back in the in the last three years a
lot of what we assumed was happening on
campus so to speak uh it was implicit
now you have to make it explicit like
what training uh the connection with the
managers all of those things are really
things where both digital tools and
explicit management time would be
required so if I were a senior executive
at Microsoft and you were my direct
supervisor how often would you want to
see my face in person
you know as often as I wanted to
um so but the the thing that that is the
key I think is like for what purpose uh
in fact I think we're all increasingly
when Peter and you ask somebody where
are you traveling to people think about
like what am I traveling for what is the
purpose uh if I come into work what do I
want to do so I think being a little
more deliberate about things that you do
while exercising your flexibility uh I
think is what's going to have to happen
and one other point on this for you as a
boss I think one of the complaints you
hear put the productivity thing to the
side is it's harder to know what
everybody's doing harder to have that
sense or to measure some of those things
and of course there are intangibles that
you can't quite measure with data
exactly so do you feel that tension and
stress because you've got a more diffuse
organization with people in different
locations the the
to your point I think you're right in
saying that the pro productivity data in
fact I see like when I'm on a team's
meeting I actually meet more people than
in a physical meeting because guess what
I can click on their profile I know who
they are I can go to the LinkedIn
profile I look them up I know more and
more people in chat on teams are
commenting in addition to what
somebody's speaking so in some sense the
multi-modal side of it I I miss it
sometimes in in-person meetings that
doesn't mean the in-person meeting
doesn't have its own Advantage which is
I have a side conversation I walk out
with somebody from a meeting so the I
think we're we're all learning how to
use both these sets of capabilities and
tools to maximize and I don't think it's
one versus the other so I don't think
there's any going back to 2019 but at
the same time it's not like we're going
to be working as if we're in 2020 and I
think that that combination is what
we're all trying to crack I'm gonna go
out for a couple questions from the
crowd in one second I'm going to ask you
one thing before I do that I just wanted
to get everybody ready and then I know
you're going to have to run but I can't
not ask you about Activision the FTC is
sued to stop the purchase you and Brad
Smith have expressed optimism about the
deal there was a report from a
competitor of Irish Reuters yesterday
that the EU is looking at challenging
the deal realistically and I know you're
publicly are expressing optimism about
it what's the time frame for a make or
break point on really pursuing this deal
in your mind and are there conditions
that just would make it impossible to
pursue look I mean he
being whatever a number four player
trying
um to add some content and create more
opportunity for more Publishers more
Gamers to be able to enjoy I don't think
Lena Khan is watching the live stream I
have to worry about it I mean it's like
if you believe in competition you should
believe in this deal uh and I I think
that you know the fact that people who
don't even make games are the largest
extractors of rents in gaming shouldn't
that tell The Regulators that where they
should be looking
um it's unbelievable to me how you know
short-sighted some of uh I would say the
way people look at competition is and in
fact the I hope the competition
authorities get focused more on
competition and that'll be a good day
okay question right here
oh hi uh Keith Frazier I run a research
institute on the future of hybrid work
it's very frustrating that fewer than 15
of your peers during this amazing remote
laboratory that they had for two years
actually looked at Reinventing how they
work and they still debate where they're
working but they haven't used your
extraordinary Tech stack to actually
reinvent the work what can you do to
build a movement that allows all the
tools you have to actually get used when
reality organizations are merely
scratching the surface
I mean I think it's like it looks like
what you're doing
but quite honestly I think the I think
it's a great point which is what's the
if you take go back to something like
business process re-engineering in the
early 90s uh there was very important to
have essentially a management Doctrine
even in order to help people deploy the
Erp systems and what have you so the
question is what is the sophistication
of the sort of modern work Doctrine so
to speak that is much more widely spread
across
um all teams and so that's I think what
everybody's understanding and and this
is where the complexity here is we have
refined as somebody said the best
collaboration tool we've all developed
is the workplace uh for 200 plus years
and so to suddenly say let's go add to
it it's sort of a tough Challenge and so
but that's the challenge uh I think we
have to learn the management techniques
uh like even how to hold a meeting going
forward
where there are two people remote and
nine people say in the meeting
the expectations of those two people are
very different today than they were two
years ago they're not going to deal with
anything second class and so if you as a
leader don't have the skills on how to
incorporate them appropriately you're
going to have a bad meeting and so I
think that that understanding like you
know it's not like the thing that you
learn uh when you join but I think
people who are growing up as Leaders
today and you know workers today are
going to learn that inherently and so
it's a generational change
you got a gentlemen right there uh the
white shirt
thank you
Representatives we start up called way
array specializing in augmented reality
I have a question what do you think will
be the impact of GPT on newspaper in
particular On The Wall Street Journal
I think they'll be able to write great
articles going into the future using GPT
I think we all know that uh currently no
news organization relies on formula
writing at all so okay uh I'll take the
gentleman back there on the stand right
yes right yes go ahead
okay
what is your opinion on on blockchain
the technology rather than
um look I mean
I am neutral to it right which is it's
it's a technology that has a set of use
cases and we support it today
um and even our distributed database
um is a good thing uh it has its uses I
think the entirety of that space we have
we've not yet found like in the context
the difference between I would say all
this web 3 and Ai and quite frankly even
metaverse is all of these three things
are all going to happen but you need to
have the killer apps what is the use
case that gets broad adoption what's the
chat GPT moment uh on blockchain uh when
when I first sort of had you know got to
know the web it was through you know the
Mosaic browser uh I think all of us
remember like I think at least the
difficulty I have in some of these other
Technologies what's that moment like
even on the meta words that's why I'm
very very keen even at ref we're you
know the global collaboration Village
and mesh that's the stuff right which is
if we can start saying hey this is just
the next generation of presents here is
how teams will evolve to include more
presence and then we're all using it and
it's mainstream then we'll know that
moment has arrived so I think we have to
keep pushing I believe in all of these
Technologies and it's up to us on the
technology side to make it more real for
more people
I think we have to stop at their uh
Sacha thank you very much for all of
your thoughts today I think we all feel
we're really on the cusp of a lot of
changes so thank you thank you so much
[Applause]